R
BAIL, SO WE WILL WAIT TO HEAR
ANYMORE UPDATES ON THAT.
>> Bret: WE WILL FOLLOW THAT.
THANK YOU.
GROUND ZERO FOR THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS IS, AS WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT, THE NATION'S PORTS, THE
PORT OF LONG BEACH AND
LOS ANGELES ARE CHOKE POINTS AS
DOZENS OF CARGO SHIPS WILL HAVE
TO WAIT WEEKS AT SEA BEFORE THEY
CAN DOCK.
AND UNLOAD THEIR PRODUCTS.
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
WILLIAM LA JEUNESSE IS OF THE
PORT TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, WILLIAM.
>> WELL, BRET, BASICALLY THE
PIPELINE OF GOODS FROM CHINA TO
THE U.S. CONSUMER IS RUNNING AT
THE PACE OF A TURTLE.
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE MILLION
CONTAINERS OFFSHORE AND WAITING
TO BE OFF-LOADED AND I AM TOLD
90% ARE LIKELY CHRISTMAS
PRESENTS.
>> I JUST KNOW THAT THERE'S A
HUGE DEMAND FOR TRUCKERS RIGHT
NOW.
SO I DECIDED TO JUST PUT MY FOOT
IN THE DOOR.
>> A DOOR THAT PAYS $50,000 A
YEAR TO START AS TRUCKING
SCHOOLS GET ASKED EVERY DAY FOR
NEW DRIVERS.
>> THE BACKUP OF SHIPS IN THE
OCEAN WAITING TO BE UNLOADED IS
REALLY BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE DRIVERS TO PICK UP THE
GOODS.
>> 58 SHIPS ARE ANCHORED OFF THE
PORTS OF L.A. AND LONG BEACH,
WAITING LEAK TO WEEKS TO
OFF-LOAD THEIR CARGO.
PART OF THE PRESIDENT'S SOLUTION
IS ADDING ANOTHER SHIFT OF
LONGSHOREMEN AT OPENING THE
PORTS TO TRUCKERS FROM 3:00 TO
7:00 A.M.
>> WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE SUPPLY
CHAIN, IT'S A SYSTEM OF SYSTEMS
AND HE ONLY WE ARE GOING TO SEE
EFFICIENCY IS IF EVERY SEGMENT
OF SUPPLY CHAIN REALIGNS.
AND WE ARE TAKING A FIRST STEP.
>> PORT OFFICIALS SAY EVERY
SEGMENT OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN MUST
WORK OR NONE OF IT WILL.
WITHOUT THE WAREHOUSE SPACE,
TRUCKERS ARE ALSO PARALYZED,
JUST LIKE THE PORTS.
TODAY THE WHITE HOUSE SAID MAJOR
FREIGHT HAULERS UPS AND FEDEX
AND RETAILERS LIKE HOME DEPOT
AND WALMART AGREED TO UTILIZE
THE NIGHT SHIFT, RELIEVING SOME
PRESSURE ON THE PORT.
>> BY TAKING THE LEAD, THEY WILL
DEMONSTRATE HOW VALUABLE THESE
NIGHTTIME OPERATIONS CAN BE AND
HOW CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THEY
ARE, ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW IN
THIS CRISIS.
>> THAT CRISIS INCLUDES
INFLATION, CONSUMER PRICES
MOVING AT A 13 YEAR HIGH CLIMBED
5.4%, HIGHER THAN THE 2% TARGET
SET BY THE FEDERAL RESERVE.
NEVERTHELESS, TREASURY SECRETARY
JANET YELLEN INSISTS HIGHER
PRICES ARE TRANSITORY.
AS FOR THE TRUCK SCHOOL
STUDENTS, THEY ARE PREPARING FOR
A LIFETIME OF WORK.
>> A LOT OF THESE BIG TRUCK
COMPANIES HAVE THE 401(K),
MEDICAL, DENTAL, VISION,
EVERYTHING.
>> OF THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS THIS
IS MORE THAN A BAND-AID.
PORT OFFICIALS HERE HOPE THIS
WILL TRIGGER A PERMANENT CHANGE
TO 24/7, BUT DON'T EXPECT
RESULTS OVERNIGHT.
GOOD CHANCE THAT IT'S GOI